expressed throughout the broadcast day are those of the speakers and not necessarily those of the
station staff, underwriters or volunteers, and where we thank you very much for choosing to
listen to us in this crowded media landscape. I know a whole bunch of people are tuning in right
now from literally around the world, certainly around the nation, to hear Ask Your Herb Doctor,
and they all missed those those occasional listeners missed that our fund drive was a couple
weeks ago. And I know you people tuning in from far away realize what a true gem Redwood Community
Radio is, and unlike any other radio in your neighborhood, which is why you are choosing to
listen to us right now. So please do in the spirit of the freedom of speech that we afford to
the Herb Doctor to get this information out there, that you support Redwood Community Radio by
on the website clicking the big blue donate here button. And most importantly, by telling four
friends about it far away and getting them to listen and getting you to them to get four friends
to listen and tell four friends to listen, etc, etc, etc. And hopefully a couple of them will kick
down a little spot of change too. And if you want to be an underwriter, you can underwrite because
you know, everybody is listening right now. Speaking of underwriting, support for the herb
doctor comes from Tony Jones who provides who provides Nia's EI, sorry, Nia's EI healing,
a hands on healing philosophy where together, Tony and her client can explore old patterns
and beliefs that no longer serve once empowered with new perspectives, different choices can be
made moving towards a life that's truly desired. Contact Tony Jones at 707-223-2724 for further
information or to schedule an appointment. It's time for Ask Your Herb Doctor.
So,
well, welcome to this month's May 2022 edition of Ask Your Herb Doctor. My name is Andrew Murray.
Sarah's not joining us this evening. She's got other plans, but next month she'll be back to
joining us in the show. It's such a beautiful drive in this evening. I've just got to say this to
folks, especially those folks that live around this area in Garboo and Humboldt County. Yeah,
it's a beautiful spring evening, warm and clear and bright and lots of hope. Now that we've had
14 inches of rain, though, I did hear the fire warnings. I'm not too sure about the early fire.
Okay, so a beautiful evening and next month, June, lo and behold, we'll be already at the solstice and
so enjoy the days lengthening. It's a beautiful, light evening and we'll continue to go that way
for another month or so. So once again, we're running the show Ask Your Herb Doctor. Again,
we're very pleased to have Dr. Raymond Peake join us with his expertise. And as always,
from 7.30 until the end of the show at 8 o'clock, we're invited to call in with questions.
And the number is 707-923-3911. Once again, 707 area code 923-3911. And I just want to say that
I have been contacted specifically to request that there are apparently a group of people out there
who actually do not like to talk, posing questions to actually face to face as it were, but would
rather leave the questions with the engineer. And I've also asked whether or not there was any way
of communicating other than by being on air live. So if anybody has any questions and they want to
pose them to the engineer, then the engineer can pass them on to me and I see he's pushed his.
This engineer really doesn't like that because people end up saying you didn't ask the question
right and wanting to call back and argue with engineers. So my rule is I will do that or they
want to say something really inflammatory. And so my personal role as an engineer, which I've tried
to train other engineers, it's a good idea to say, I will repeat five non-inflammatory word. If you
can say a five word question, then I will do that because otherwise everybody they call back and
they want this and I didn't get understand their question right. Okay. I don't understand. I don't
understand the boiling, the boiling sentiment underneath that. Okay. So I've always been,
well on your show, I generally don't because you always ask their name and where they're calling
for. So I understand that you want to have that more personal connection with your people,
but I'm more than happy to do five words. Okay. Whoever's listening who doesn't want to speak
and has got a succinct question they can put to the engineer in five simple words, that would be
awesome. So like the and of and stuff, you know, we don't worry about that. Okay. So small little,
small little words don't count folks. Okay. All right. So once again, now we're joined by Dr.
Raymond Pete. I've got an intro that I'm going to read. I'm going to read it after we've got Dr. Peat
on the air. Dr. Peat, are you with us? Yes. Okay. Thanks so much for joining us as always.
And as always, for those people who perhaps have never heard of you before and don't know
anything about you, would you please outline your professional and scientific backgrounds
so people know how and where you're coming from? In the fifties and sixties, I was working in
humanities, literature, painting, philosophy, and my interest in how consciousness works led me to
decide to understand language and art. It would help to understand what the brain is and how the
brain is conscious. And so I went back to graduate school in 1968, University of Oregon, attending to
concentrate on brain studies. But I found that they were the department working on and the brain
was extremely dogmatic. And so I looked around and found that the other end of the organism,
the reproductive system, the professors in that area were actually scientific and didn't throw out
data just because it didn't agree with the dogma. And so I did my dissertation on
the oxidative aging process as it relates to the reproductive system. And it turned out that
gives a very interesting background to things such as how the brain works,
which is a theme that was existing in biology 100 years ago, how electrons and biological
energy power perceptions and consciousness had been squeezed out already right from
early years of science. The corporations were squeezing out the freely exploring
researchers and subsidizing people who would work for their corporate interests.
There we go. Okay, thanks for that. I guess we'll open up the dialogue. I just wanted to
back up a little from last month. Now again, it's always espoused at the beginning of the show that
the views and opinions offered by the speakers of those of the speaker are not of the radio show,
so let's get that back out there again. And we've been since the very beginning of 2020,
skeptical, to say the least, of the organization and/or rollout of what's become the COVID pandemic.
And what I think at this point in time has fizzled into a non-event at this point. We are,
by all accounts, seemingly over what was forecast in the beginning, but obviously you and I and many
other people, especially other notable scientists, I'm not saying I'm a notable scientist, but
definitely somebody who's looking at data and questioning and reasoning and using science and
looking at all sides of an argument to come to a valid and level judgment about what is and what
isn't. Something that seemed to be perpetuated during this "pandemic" was the mass formation
psychosis of the mindset of the population. This is not just a national, this is international
worldwide psychosis that I think can be only described as such, that the directives, and we'll
call them directives, not orders, but we'll call the directives and the guidance, we'll call it
guidance and not demands, but given by governments, health organizations, and vested interests who
"have authority over us." And there's another subject about the current administration giving
parts of our national sovereignty a way to the World Health Organization and the United Nations,
which is "very alarming," because they essentially will have control over any pandemic and the
American policy towards a pandemic. And so that's pretty scary, folks. We believe that this nation
is one nation under God and we have a constitution and a bill of rights, et cetera, and we are
self-determinant. But apparently, just the other day, Joe Biden signed this thing, which essentially
is the beginning of what would be giving over these rights to the United Nations, for crying
out loud. Okay, so it's the United Nations who have perpetuated most of what's happened during
this COVID pandemic, which pretty much centered, at least in the early days for sure, around Europe
and Europe's response to the COVID infection and outbreak. Obviously, we've talked at length about
the origins of it and it's very questionable. And we've also talked about the actual numbers
of deaths and it's actually very close to a normal influenza season. There's really actually no data
to show that it's significantly higher, but yet the rhetoric has continued again and again and
again that this is something completely alarming and has to be taken control of and lockdowns and
face masks and social isolation and everything that's gone on with it has definitely espoused
what the World Economic Forum and Klaus Schwab and his minions have been working at here really,
I guess actually, and we'll talk about technocracy as well later, since the 1930s.
The subject of transhumanism is going to be my question to you, but I just wanted to bring out
again, as a kind of preface wrap up from last month, mass formation, psychosis. And so this
in essentially in the beginning took the form of the vaccine narrative and the imperative that
governments knew best and were the arbiters of truth. Dissenting scientists were vilified or
cancelled, which is very popular in today's culture by the masters of the universe that we hear about
the technocrat and the media groups and vested individuals who seem to have a lot of sway,
especially through social media, over the masses like never before, and the totalitarians amongst
them, veiled in this social media-esque cuddly and cute thought police, would monitor what you said
and would basically strike you out or cancel you if you were saying things that they didn't like
or agree. And also the sanctioning of free speech and the right to self-determination. Again,
I mentioned this is enshrined in our constitution in law, and the law is how the subject that I'm
going to go onto, which was Raina Formish, his legal campaign, which if you, let me give you the
website for which there's a huge amount of superb chronologically rather documented
allegations backed by science. The website is https.com/radical, R-A-T-I-C-A-L dot org,
and then /pandemicparallaxview, it goes on /lawsuits-c19-claims.html, but that should get
you there, so /radical.org/pandemicparallaxview/ lawsuits. So since the beginning of the early,
since early 2020, when I mentioned that a lot of what was coming out in the media was definitely
hysterical, and there were lots of ER doctors that were just saying this was just so unusual,
and this was during the whole ventilator tragedy in the beginning, there were many good ER doctors
saying people were just dying on mass from ventilators, this was not a usual lung disease
they were looking at, it did not fit the usual pattern, blah blah blah, and we talked about how
people were killed on ventilators, especially if they were given remdesivir during their treatment,
which is still used incredibly, and that the basis for all of the startling and scaremongering
directives and orders not to do, and not to be with, and to be locked down, and wear masks,
and fear rolled out in 2020. Rhino Formik started a law suit with many other legal experts,
as well as doctors and other medical people who are also looking at the data and saying
what is going on, this does not make sense. So they formed a collective, and they called this
collective the German Corona Commission, and this commission essentially gathered
steam and got more and more scientists on board who were skeptical because what was being seen
did not make sense, and there is on that website that I just gave you the URL for a huge chronological
list of everything pretty much has gone on, I couldn't believe how much information was on,
and we talk about the age of information and the dissemination thereof, and obviously
we're going to get into the controlling the narrative side of information and disinformation,
and of course who wants to hear lies and deceit etc, we want the truth, I mean all of us do,
I'm sure. So looking at the subject of transhumanism from Klaus Schwab's own words,
talking about people will own nothing and be happy, and that what we're seeing now,
especially just looking at the stock market having its worst successive eight week
loss is almost approaching the 1930s collapse of Wall Street is actually on a week by week
performance basis, it's getting very close to that even though no one's actually talking about
a collapse of the economy as yet, they are starting to talk about a recession folks,
but we've known it at least for the last year and a half or two years even since the beginning of
Covid and seeing this as just another scapegoat for the great reset which was part of Klaus Schwab's
world economic forum debate saying that these people, these vested interests of which nearly
all of it is private entities and corporations that are huge, that have the ownership of much
of what we take for granted, want to steer humanity in a certain way and so when I looked at
technocracy and I looked at transhumanism and I looked at the background of it from the 30s until
now, it's like wow it kind of totally makes sense that obviously governments want a control over
their population, they don't want too many people thinking outside the box or thinking freely and
it's in their interest through whatever means and it's become a technological technocratic means
that they now have vast amounts of data and algorithms that are used to tell exactly what
you like, what you don't like, what you will buy, what you won't buy and where you're probably a
political background or beliefs and ideals are with a pretty good degree of accuracy if you're
on social media and you post all this stuff, the algorithms can figure it all out quite well it's
not rocket science but they've deployed it against us and so for that very reason I've never signed
on to social media, I'm not tooting my horn or anything but from the beginning I never liked the
idea of it so back in 2002 and 3 and 4 when YouTube was gaining steam you know people were getting on
Facebook and stuff, I never looked at it as something that to be encouraged. So Dr. Peat
transhumanism is this premise that biological evolution will be overtaken by genetic wearable
and implantable or injectable technologies that artificially expedite the evolutionary process
called the great reset. What are your thoughts on this? I know you have mentioned snippets here
and there about where you feel your opinion of this but what's your... In the 1940s and 50s
I knew people who had become convinced members of Technocracy Incorporated and the stock market
that you mentioned that has been one of the techniques to take over assets of the world.
Every time the value of the stock collapses suddenly small investors are the ones who
get killed by it and the big giant corporations get bigger and so it's like a ratchet to shake
loose the bulk of the investors in stock and constantly refine the ownership to a smaller
and smaller group and the people who were injured by the starvation even the extreme breakdown of
the economy in 1930 people with good intentions said well the corporate engineers know what needs
to be done and so if we turn the operation of the economy over to scientists and engineers
they will make sure that we don't have these collapses except that the scientists and engineers
are working for the big corporations that engineer to collapse so these people were well-meaning but
very gullible they would have caravans across the country in the 30s 40s and 50s they drove
gray cars with a yin-yang symbol on the doors and attracted lots of attention but they were
really just a minor sign of what was really going on with the shake down of ownership
concentrating more and more the control over over society
corporations right from the very beginning
the first generations of scientists in the 17th and 18th centuries
were of the ruling class basically people who had the least heard money to do their own research
but then by the 19th century the corporations were taking control
and 1950 was really a turning point when the government came right out and said that
big science is the only science and government has to direct finance and control big science
so there hasn't been any pretense of science being a free enterprise thing anymore that
the journals and universities were absolutely taken over by the funding of the giant corporations
and the government funding agencies so looking looking at the definition again and i think this
again is the language folks i think the direction of the language and the confusion is a tool the
when i looked at technocracy earlier on they couch this in terms of the green economy
sustainable development well i hear sustainable development all over humboldt county and i have
done for quite a while i'm not saying it's bad i'm saying that the interpretation of
the green economy and sustainable development doesn't seem to upset anybody it sounds like a
good thing i mean why wouldn't you want development to be sustainable rather than unsustainable and
why wouldn't you want green over black as a kind of means you know i agree totally with the fossil
fuel you know the abolition of fossil fuel in favor of better greener less poisoning polluting
things of course i do and i like the idea of sustainable development over completely exploited
and unsustainable raping of our natural resources of course i mean that's a that's a absolutely no
brainer but in terms of the technocracy and these terms green economy and sustainable development
it's actually a very different picture that is being foisted on the nations of the world if the
world economic forum get their way if transhumanism comes to pass if people don't wake up from what
they've been subjected to if they're not made aware of the actual end game of what this is all
about where it's going it's going to be almost too late for a lot of people the way they manipulate
science is it in the background and so it involves a selling of an ideology to the general population
which justified is a reductionist view of biology and evolution the intelligence of
organism of development has been made to seem ridiculous and ruled out of science
the background includes a philosophy of logic how the brain and logic are contributing
to truth in science they had to get at the very essence of mind and intelligence and
rule out intelligence from science in favor of randomness as being the key to everything
evolution supposedly is a matter of infinite random events and when you look at how that
really works it is a degrading process not an advancing process and people like Barbara
McClintock who in the 1940s and 50s showed that a plant a corn for particular material that plants
use intelligence intelligent modification of their own genes to improve their situation
and that actual objective scientific work ruled her out of the functional
world of science she wasn't invited to conferences her papers weren't published
and so from the 1950s for several decades she was non-existent in the world of
evolution genes and the concept of what an organism is but then Monsanto was being criticized
for making new organisms seeds that they could control to sell their round up
various forms of insecticide and weed control that their plants could endure
people were criticizing that as a very dangerous process and in the universities
I was at the University of Oregon at that time and the essentially all of the professors
went along with genetic engineering will be done by smart people like salmon so nothing could go
wrong let me help let me hold your thought there dr Pete um so ask your of dr camey d
garberville 91.1 fm from now and we have a caller from now until the end of the show at eight o'clock
you're invited to call in the questions and number 707 923 3911 I wanted to say one last thing before
we take this next call that the whole point of transhumanism as an evolution through intelligent
design relies on intelligent design folks and the mRNA vaccine rollout has been anything but
intelligent and we'll get into that after this caller so caller you're on the air way from what's
your question they just had less than five words oh okay go ahead a very good germane one please
define transhumanism right so okay so as I said at the beginning here it's the premise that biological
evolution will be overtaken by genetic wearable and implantable or injectable folks technologies
that artificially expedite the evolutionary process so this is transhumanism where ultimately
you hear about uh elon musk going on about chips implantable chips in the brain that will be uh
that'll make you a better person folks because we're not created well enough so I think we have
another caller caller yeah your caller you're on the air where where you're from and what's your
question yeah I'm from Los Angeles um so I wanted to explain it as quick as possible and uh
let's see if you guys understand me so my wife um has been having a pro prolonged bleeding
okay and um she um started taking progesterone so the progesterone 2.5 milligrams has helped
cut the bleeding off but when she stops taking the progesterone the bleeding continues so now
the because they found something in the ultrasound they want to do a hysteroscopy and uh what is a
curettage uh endometrial crud crud curettage right yeah curettage but they've um and I know
and I know Dr. Peatrecommends thyroid but let's say they do find something some abnormal cells what
would you know be the next step like to really reverse this I well I guess first things first
let's just clarify you said she was given progesterone is it actual progesterone or
is it a progestin do you know what type of progesterone it is all I know all I know it says
meth m e t h progesterone so it's prescribed I didn't actually read but all the ingredients
progesterone okay Dr. Peatwell what about meth prog I'm not sure about meth progesterone
and the patients had their wife of the person to call her getting bleeding that was seemed
to be controlled by it but then what was the dose of progesterone 2.5 milligrams was that once a day
or yeah that can't be real progesterone that much progesterone wouldn't do anything right
so are you sure that that dose was 2.5 milligrams yeah yeah correct because she was on 10 milligrams
a few few days ago right right and it was giving her headaches and I mean it did cut the bleeding
like it got lighter but the symptoms the side effects of the prescribed 10 milligram progesterone
just too strong has she has she gotten hold of any natural progesterone no we never tried down
that's the thing she's never I mean the diet is pretty clean but other she's never tried the
thyroid she's never tried the natural progesty you guys recommend okay and it's kind of hard to get
her to you know get into the rhythm of doing those supplements but I'm wondering if if Dr. Peat thinks
if you know the growth is abnormal cells because they'll give her the results yeah and does he
recommend that that she takes those tests well if you yeah if she's got endometriosis and she's got
an uncontrolled estrogen dominant physiology if they're talking about a hysterectomy I would
definitely advise against a hysterectomy because unless she's really exhausted natural progesterone
as a means to counteract the estrogen dominance that she's almost certainly got because of her
endometriosis then you need to rule that out first so um and the function of thyroid is to
increase natural progesterone production while decreasing estrogen and so it has a very high
success rate in endometriosis because that is caused by a thyroid deficiency with estrogen excess
and I've known several people who on the very first day of starting to correct their thyroid
function their symptoms disappeared and for a few months I was keeping track of I think it was 36
women who were told they needed a biopsy or partial hysterectomy because abnormal cells
and within a month of using supplements including thyroid every one of those 36 women
went back and they could find no evidence of abnormal cells oh wow and but the thyroid should
be like you guys uh I I've heard you mentioned when you know getting a cytoplasm from Mexico or is
there a desiccated thyroid that we could find in the market that will be you know pretty uh well
tolerated yeah yeah but one thing to keep in mind is that the T4 is a stabilizing
influence that has a half-life in the body of about two weeks and so if you try to get
the quick effect with the C4 containing armor, thyroid or you know plus you're going to
have a good effect immediately but then you'll overdose doing it for about
four or five days you'll run up again and the thyroid okay okay so so Dr. Peatyou don't recommend
she'd what about the hysteroscopy though to like kind of diagnose and the biopsy are you
not in favor of those things or I mean what would be your advice if the doctor does want to do the
well to see if the signs of too much bleeding pain endometriosis symptoms
if you can stop that very quickly with a combination of the right hormones
thyroid and progesterone if you can stop the symptoms quickly then within a couple of weeks
these abnormal cells will probably have been normalized or or shed right right because they're
just there the abnormal cells the site is about they're about three millimeters but I mean I guess
she has to make a choice if she does want to go ahead and just see if they acknowledge that but
I thank you guys for your time also thanks for for the answering the emails I know you guys are
bond with email so I appreciate it stay on hey fellow please stay on for a second there we have
another caller here who has some experience with your issue or your wife's issue caller you're on
as well okay hi um I wanted to tell you that I had a similar situation five years ago and uh
I went into the hospital with it and I used project uh the project the the kind that Ray recommend
and seno plus and spider mel and as soon as I got my p3 up the bleeding stopped and I continued to
this day to use progesterone um they wanted to uh do a hysterectomy then they gave me drugs
that stop the bleeding which created blood clots then they said oh we'll we'll uh do radiation
and we'll do all these things and I said no and you know I said you're not as clear I wish I could
hear you clear and have uh maybe a way to put a cost or email you I can't hear clearly hey both
of you I will take you we'll go back to the to the show and I will have both of you on and I will
get your information and pass it to each other okay so we just yeah just stay on the line okay
okay thank you more than happy this okay great all right well that was fortuitous great okay um
so Dr Peter with you're still with us right oh what was that that's okay I think there was
another caller a female caller called in who said she had exactly the same situation and she was
quite quite happy to give the person uh the what she had done which is very much what you had
already suggested but so I think the two people are going to talk uh face to face or personally
we're not face to face obviously but I think they're so far away okay so um you're listening
to ask Your Herb Doctor KMUD Garberville 91.1 FM from now until eight o'clock you invited to call in
numbers 707 923 3911 707 923 3911 Dr Raymond Pete uh guest speaker uh so Dr Pete
I guess let's kind of move on uh I think I just want to just basically wrap up I had one more
comment about the barber with sintuck uh not getting any recommendations in silence for
at 20 or 30 years finally when Monsanto was running into the reality that the process is
very deadly much much causes much more harm than than benefit except to their profits
they decided they needed some kind of propaganda and to say that
Martin McClintock had demonstrated that plants uh used genetic engineering
shows that that's a perfectly natural thing so if the plants could do it on their own
it must be just as safe as Monsanto does it which is a total misunderstanding of what what biology
is oh my gosh okay well I can hardly believe that that in terms of hearing it the way that
the way that you said that for sure but that really ties into the fact that the the whole GMO
thing uh I know everybody here probably in Humboldt County was totally against it I think
it was 25 I think I still got the t-shirt the um that's what was it some GMO uh initiative
that we were funding and uh was an anti-GMO anti-Monsanto we don't want you genetically
engineered seeds here thanks after farm farmers all over the world uh were getting sued uh by
Monsanto because some of their corn had GMO corn uh present because of uh you know biological life
transmitting and transferring you know genetic information from the statements of one flower
flowering corn uh into a neighboring organic corn and um you know there's very a lot of cases of
small farmers put out of business by Monsanto's lawsuits against them and um I think actually now
and quote me folks if I'm not right but I think actually now Monsanto do have patents on what
was considered unpatentable material because it's biological um that was one of the big one of the
big uh kind of court cases was how can you how can you possibly put a patent on naturally occurring
compounds like plants and food and the virologists have patented all these segments
of viral genomes so that if it's potentially a pandemic in the future which has this
little bit of a genome in it then they can get a patent on the vaccine to it yep and we covered
all of that in a previous show about all the data surrounding the patents that have been issued
since the beginning of the 2000 from 2000 2001 and two through to the present and this was all
born uh out in data that um Robert Malone inventor were inventor he was the person who did his PhD on
mRNA technology he was the person who bought this out that all of the patents that were issued
uh and initially were not allowed because of the quote unquote you know
inadmissibility of it because it was just not in the remit of the patent office to do this
um slowly but surely this started getting patents granted and it was the um it was the professor
I think he's a he's a professor or doctor and actually I've not got his name on the tip of
my tongue dr p i remember you might have his name who was the patent office uh he was basically
scanning all the patents that were being issued and he's basically got a huge database again of
all the companies that were issued patents on coronaviruses and other viruses and it's
all part of a big plant have secure the rights to these things David Martin that's it David Martin
thank you so we did a show on that and that's all very clear and obvious okay so i guess to wrap up
the transhumanism things people just need to have a listen to this data again uh on the audio archives
and i wanted someone just texted me something they reminded me i want to give a shout out to the late
stephanie galboy who was a great oh no wait late yes she died she was killed in redway a few years
ago but she was a great great fighter against the gmo issue and uh we have her to thank okay well
yep god bless you stephanie i didn't even know that i'd not heard okay so the uh the wrapping up of the
the wrapping up of right way it's not wrapped up it's still ongoing but rhino formic and again i
want to quote this um or just reinstate the fact that law is law for a reason right we all need
i'm not saying i'm a big legalist by any means uh we need a law you know so that there is a recourse
for people who do things that we all don't collectively agree as a society should be allowed
like murdering people and raping people and you know all of those things that we need laws for
so we can't have a lawless society because i don't think that's ever going to work because
not one of us is good right it's just the way it is that all of us to some degree or another
have intents that are not quote unquote good i'm not saying that we're all bad either so don't quote
me out of out of context um but we need a law to be living by and that's the whole point of our
constitution our constitution was founded by the framers here that came and fled the tyranny in
europe and the overarching laws which were not just and they came here and provided their own
system in the constitution and the bill of rights to have a free and open society with the constitution
that protected people and gave us all inalienable rights to the pursuit of life liberty and happiness
so i think we have a caller so before i carry on with any more of that let's take the next
good evening hi you're on the airway from hello you're on the airway from what's your question
i'm from shelter cove i'd like to mention that vitamin d is extremely important for women as
they enter menopause it's extremely important for women period i had a low low low vitamin d level
down to 16 16 and it took me 11 years in this community to diagnose my hashimoto hypothyroidism
and i'm not crazy okay and i'd also like to okay well i totally agree with what you said there
vitamin d deficiency is rampant uh just probably worldwide i know definitely in the states here
um there are lots and lots of people whose labs show very deficient vitamin d and they have
increased the reference range for vitamin d to take account of the fact that people are pretty
much deficient and how useful it is especially for calcium metabolism and for its antiviral
immune stimulating anti-cancer benefit amongst many other things that vitamin d does and so yeah
make sure your folks you're not just going to get it from the sun because it's just not the way it
is and so most people are deficient and a good vitamin d supplement of 5000 are you a day should
get most people into a fairly good range okay so dr p um patient doctor relationship um
again it's another sign of the times um but i'd love your comment on it the
i found out the california is california folks i don't know uh what it is about california i'm
not bashing it i love california i think the environment is beautiful but some of the
you know it always talks about the california fruits and nuts and um but it also talks about
california where the great things started the great movement started and the great change
happened you know so it's all good um and so it's not good okay so california assembly bill 2098 folks
and it's out of our hands because it's up it's down to our senators our legislators and it's not
a voting issue the california assembly bill 2098 would make and it's going through the assembly
right now and it doesn't look as though it's going to get stopped it seems to have full
democratic support uh would make it easy and easier for the medical board of california to
discipline doctors who promote covid 19 misinformation by classifying it as unprofessional
contact so let's just think about that covid misinformation so anything that is anything
which does not conform to government guidelines issued as scientific fact when evidence exists
which as scientific fact itself completely refutes all claims made by government mandates
so think about that folks you talk about free speech i talked about open debate open debate
is critical to a free and functioning society we need to hear everybody's point of view folks it's
not one side i don't want to give a one-sided view of things and it might come across that
sometimes because of the covid uh debate and everything that's happened as a result of it
because there's plenty of scientific evidence to show there is a very different picture um to be
told and a very different story to be told and that's why people like rhinophomic and the german
corona committee are going at it through the legal channels because the law gives impartial
hearings to the case so weighing in are with scientific people uh people that whose
entire lives are based on the subject they're talking on with evidence written and documented
evidence in a court of law is the only way that progress will get made obviously you've got to
think about whether or not the courts are biased or the you know the supremes for example are biased
but when you go that far and you don't get the righteous judgment being issued then you know
there's something wrong so the lawsuit that's being formed by rhinophomic and his other lawyers and
other professionals and they're not the only people not just in germany but around the world in
australia and other countries there are groups that are legally taking up this challenge to show
that what's been done has been completely unconstitutional and needs address now otherwise
it's not going to stop so for those people who think it's all fun and groovy and that it's a
great thing what we've gone through and it was for our benefit i'd really ask you to question
question yourself and look at look at the data and see what's happened and see just how many
people have suffered as a result of this quote unquote experiment that's gone on um so doctor
patient confidentiality in assembly bill 2098 will basically make it illegal for a doctor to use his
professional judgment folks as your doctor their professional judgment having qualified and passed
the bar and entered the field of being a doctor talking to a patient in complete confidentiality
not disclosing anything that has been told him or her about the subject being consulted that that
doctor actually now will have legal ramifications to answer to if they don't tow the party line and
that's becoming a very socialist term in terms of the party line and i'm definitely not one to want
misinformation and disinformation and lies to be propagated and i want open debate and
scientific debate and verifiable results and i want the truth to come out always have done
but dr p have patient uh doctor consultation and privacy and uh
california assembly bill 2098 what do you think of that until just recently the medical licensing
system has been used to exclude alternate theories of medicine chiropractic homeopathy
of the alternative old-fashioned herbal therapy things were controlled by the powers of medical
monopoly and the doctors were fine with that but uh now the the government has decided that
they don't have even the power to define what their own monopoly believes and does
and the government has taken away that autonomy which that really they shouldn't have had such
powerful control over defining who who is a physician but now they are they've lost
everything along with the power to deal privately with the patient and now the government is the
final and only word on what constitutes medicine unbelievable okay i have another another point
that i think we'll get through um again it's on the same kind of the same kind of topic folk
the ministry of truth i think we've all probably heard in the last week or so the last couple of
weeks the ministry of truth that our current administration uh is bringing into power to make
sure that we're not misinformed or fed lies or disinformation and um you know i don't know
i don't know how but maybe people that are listening to this think that this is disinformation
somehow but um the ministry of truth the department of homeland security has announced the formation
of the disinformation government's board so the disinformation governance board the dgb they
actually they put it on pause yes they did you've preempted and you've jumped the gun engineer you
shouldn't do that so the dgb it's a little bit like the kgb right but it's the dgb yes it has
been dissolved but um i think unfortunately it's going to morph into something else because i think
it was too in your face um i think it caused too much of the reaction so i'm sure there'll be some
other covert way of bringing this thing to pass because i believe that it is in the interest
of the kind of administration to make sure that they have full control of everything that's said
and taught etc etc so um doctor p yeah they put that on hold um but another ministry of truth is
probably going to exist at some point in time yeah yeah but the government had been working directly
through uh uh the uh science organizations like facebook and uh wiki yeah wikipedia yeah and uh
the social interacting uh groups they they simply gave orders the companies were created
by funding uh coming from the pentagon and so they've been committed all along to
cooperating with the government but the uh canceling of or censorship of messages
thousands and thousands of accounts are being closed uh i might be recommendation of the
government so they don't really need a formal agent to do what they've been doing all along
okay well it's uh 7 56 here almost three minutes to the hour uh doctor p thank you so much for
joining us okay thank you okay so uh we didn't get to the end of everything that i wanted to
discuss but i appreciate the callers that called in and um dr Raymond Peat his uh he can be accessed
his information his scientific and yeah yeah he referenced you know fully referenced what
he writes on his website and he's written in his papers is fully referenced so it's not just his
opinion um www dot ray peat r-a-y-p-e-a-t dot com i wanted to get into the subject of the baby milk
formula crisis but we'll have to address that next month hopefully uh anyway it may actually
be a good thing i don't want to be um flippant or uh inflammatory in any way um but essentially
contains a lot of things that dr p would totally disagree with like the n minus three omega oils
and um it also brings into question why mothers uh should not be doing what mothers do when they
give birth i know there are some mothers who are unable and obviously that is a complete and utter
reason to want a supplement but uh we'll talk about that and in artificial meat and meat
replacements and um why we want to just turn against everything that we were um traditionally
doing uh because folks it's all wants to go into a non-natural direction and whilst sustainable
development and green economics may sound like a good thing when you look at the central banks
behind it and you look into it a little deeper folks don't be don't be guiled by it because
actually it's a weapon that's really going to be used against people's freedom so my name is Andrew
Murray and we can be reached at westernbotanicalmedicine.com uh until June 2022 and it'll
be round about mid-summer i wish you a great spring and uh speak to you then good night
i'll let you know that the owens fire broke out south of point arena on the medicino coast
around 3 p.m as of 7 45 the owens fire has grown to 30 acres it's about 5 contained resources will
remain on the scene overnight highway one remains closed in that region and traffic is backing up
mandatory evacuation orders remain in place for residents on owens road sorry bill owens road and
schooner gulch road to highway one the best evacuation road is east to 10 mile cut off road
about 60 residents are impacted more updates on this fire can be readily found at www
mendo ready.org and shaka will have updates as they are sent to him by our news team
thank you so much for listening the next sound you will hear will be the dulcetones of shaka
(upbeat music)